this week on
brian ross investigates no matter who's
in the white house
what are the three most important steps
to fight off the covet 19 pandemic
what about thanksgiving christmas and
the year-end holidays should the us
follow britain's lead and shut down the
country for a month
and how soon can we realistically expect
a vaccine
we're joined by the former deputy
surgeon general dr boris lushniak
with important words about our public
health
plus a new lawsuit alleges sales reps
for a major health care company
use gifts of foods and posed as
essential personnel
to gain access to america's nursing
homes the
staff are considered essential health
care workers report to work as scheduled
governor's stay at home order does not
apply our interview
was the woman who would not follow
orders they brought food donuts
gifts whatever they could
come up with to try and get themselves
in the door and
this week's winners and losers in the
media see
if you agree with the editors of
mediaite about who's on top
and who is not from the lawn crime trial
network
this is brian ross investigates
and good evening thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always tonight
by my colleague at law and crime rhonda
schwartz
and rhonda we begin with the one thing
we should know for sure by the end of
this week
and that is the kovid 19 pandemic is
raging
seemingly out of control rhonda
that's right it's an enormous spike it
keeps growing
500 000 new cases just this week giving
the united states the unwelcome
distinction
of leading the world in new cases and
new deaths brian
to get better insight into all this
we're joined tonight by dr boris lushna
the former u.s public health
commissioner
acting surgeon general and now the dean
of the school of public health at the
university of maryland
dr lustinick thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me on
brian
let me start by asking you what can be
done now
what should we be doing in this country
and what should we do about the upcoming
holidays thanksgiving
and all the year-end holidays including
christmas
well first of all we have to go back to
the basics and to some extent
it is a repetition of the same
recommendations public health have been
giving
to the united states to the world since
all this started
number one masks get those masks on
and wear them with vigor right wear them
with a sign of that they're not a
political state
but in fact they are a way of showing
that we care for others and we care
about our own health
the idea of physical distancing the idea
that we can't get together in groups yes
we are all tired
of this phobia there is the concept of
copic fatigue
we need to be able to get out there
right to be able through the world of
internet through the world of telephone
old-fashioned reddit
letter writing to connect with people
but group gatherings really are a major
problem
in terms of credibility and the third
component which i'll repeat yet again
is washing of hands making sure that we
are clean
and not touching our faces and passing
diseases onto
others those are our three critical
components and as we prepare for the
holidays coming up
the key feature here is this is going to
be a holiday season
unlike any others that we have
experienced in our lifetimes
and the key component of this is the
idea of
families gathering together the idea of
many of us
sitting in houses or in rooms eating
dinner together
that's going to have to be postponed
because the reality is we're seeing
spikes because of this
this this regression if you will of our
awareness
of physical and social distancing in the
midst of all
so the holidays celebrate celebrate
using brand new techniques of connecting
with our family members but avoid the
large group gathering
that's pretty strong medicine for the
american public as a expert in public
health how do you persuade americans
to follow that those guidelines well
once again uh you know going back to
what ronda had just discussed a little
while ago is
right now we're not doing well and right
now we're setting ourselves up for
a very long winter unless we do this
right
what we've seen oftentimes throughout
this whole time period
of this program 19 pandemic is what is
every time we've had
large group get-togethers we've seen
huge spikes afterwards
and this is measurable after the
memorial day holiday after the july 4th
holiday after the labor day holiday
the minute that we let down our guard
and wants to celebrate
as if nothing happened that's where our
nation gets into trouble
and what i'm asking people to do is this
is sacrifice but this is sacrifice for
the bigger good
and the reality is what sars cov2 the
virus that causes kobit 19
is transmissible from person to person
if i can drop
right a curtain in between you and me i
can stop
that transmission and that metaphorical
curtain
is at times me being separated from
others
this is not easy and and as i mentioned
earlier a lot of us have over 50 right
we're tired of
having to live like this what i'm asking
america to do
is a little while longer and we can
actually
make incredible pains
dr lushnik a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
so what about the hope for a vaccine we
saw some trials start with great promise
and then they paused
they started again are we getting closer
to a vaccine
rather we definitely are getting closer
uh it's been an
incredible journey in these last you
know 10
11 months since all this started i do
want everyone to reflect on the fact
that
this all started december 31st was the
first time that the world health
organization
office in china was informed of an
outbreak a small
outbreak unknown ideology of diseases
people with pneumonia so we've been 10
and a half months in
and especially on the vaccine front
incredible progress
right now we have worldwide around 50
vaccines five zero vaccines that are
in some aspect of clinical trials and
over 80 vaccines that are still being
tested so this is a worldwide induction
we've made incredible progress yet
we're at the critical point with a
handful of vaccines which is called the
phase
three trials where all of a sudden the
vaccine is being given to larger numbers
of people
and now there's a reckoning time right
there's a time to say
does this work and does this not cause
harm right
two important facets for this this is
gonna take a while so the way i'm
looking at it
is at best in the first quarter of 21
will
we see some vaccines coming to the top
that have enough
information have enough of that critical
data to be
able to be looked at as potential
uh parts of our armamentarium
against povid19 but i have to stress
rhonda and this is really critical
the minute we get a vaccine that's
that's licensed by the fda
in the united states is not the end of
this pandemic
this just allows us to utilize a brand
new weapon against that
we will continue these other public
health measures wearing the mask
physical distancing and hand washing for
a while
into 21 until enough people have the
vaccine
and and we can actually make changes in
the environment
of profit 19 as a result of this
vaccination program that will likely
take place sometime in 21.
all right dr boris lesniak the dean of
the university of maryland school of
public health thank you so much for
joining us
valuable insight coming up allegations
against a major u.s healthcare company
allegations that sales reps sneaked into
nursing homes with gifts of food
to sell their services when we come back
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime
trial network
whenever that happy day comes when we're
back to normal from this covet 19
pandemic there will no doubt need to be
a number of investigations
but what happened during the pandemic
and no doubt one of the focuses
has to be on what happened in america's
nursing homes rhonda
that's right 38 of deaths from
covid were nursing home patients and
staff in long-term care
facilities in nursing homes around the
country 87 000 people
according to a special study by the new
york times
and one thing that should not be
overlooked is what was alleged in a
civil lawsuit filed by a
employee of a major u.s health care
company she was put on
unpaid medical leave after she
complained about what was going on
the lawsuit was filed by a california
salesperson for the vetus
health care company which sells hospice
care for the elderly
her name is christina eisenhacker what
rey's
concerns on my part is
that we were ordered to ignore public
health
officials orders and go into hospitals
nursing homes and doctors offices that
stated that they were close to vendors
and we were instructed specifically to
ignore those instructions
and uh rewarded for even sneaking into
those facilities if necessary and your
job was what
to sell what um
my job was to sell hospice
so you would sneak in essentially when
you say sneak in what do you mean
well i i wouldn't once those orders came
down um
i refused to participate and
um sat back while i watched other
employees
actually sneak into these facilities and
were encouraged and rewarded by the
management
as part of her lawsuit she obtained
these pictures taken by colleagues who
followed the orders
one with the caption sneaky sneaky what
you're seeing in those pictures brian
is sales people being
taking selfies with doctors nurses
and administrators at hospitals nursing
homes
and and doctor's offices they brought
food donuts
gifts whatever they could
come up with to try and get themselves
in the door
and at this point there was a complete
ban on people going into nursing homes
and various
doctors offices but your colleagues did
they did that's right in its promotional
videos online
the vedas company boasts that it has
been a leader in providing
hospice end-of-life healthcare to
patients in 14 states and the district
of columbia
we have over 12 000 professionals with
the expertise that comes from helping
the thousands of people
day and night who depend on us
eisenhocker says she and other
salespeople were told
they should consider themselves
essential personnel
and therefore restrictions on entering
nursing homes
did not apply she received this phone
message from the company
alvida's staff are considered essential
health care workers
report to work as scheduled governor
state home order does not apply
carry your v dispatch to identify
yourself as a health care employee in
the event that you require proof of
employment
it seemed that these orders were coming
from the top down uh this is a company
that's in
uh 14 states all over the country and
um i knew what they were doing was was
illegal
and as i watched uh people on television
talking about the outbreaks in nursing
homes and um
and and in hospitals and listened to
family members crying that they couldn't
even
visit their dying mothers fathers
brothers sisters
um i i really couldn't stand by
and and watch this happen without saying
anything
so i i didn't really feel like i had a
choice brian
and yet at the same time that the loved
ones can't go in the nursing homes
the sales people are going in claiming
they're essential personnel
that's right and and i'd like to add on
top of that
that they were not only um going in
claiming that they were essential they
were also going in
um without proper ppe so um
even what the quote-unquote essential
healthcare workers
were required to do from a preventative
standpoint vitas wasn't even observing
that
the president and ceo of vedas
healthcare nick westfall
declined our invitation to appear on the
program and respond to the allegations
in the lawsuit
westfall was in washington back in march
to meet with vice president pence and
the kova 19 task force
where the need to protect nursing homes
was prioritized
generally we we monitor our nursing
homes
for abuse and to collect but at the
president's direction we're going to
focus exclusively on ensuring
that those who are in nursing homes
people operating in nursing homes like
many of the ceos that we met with today
are complying with the new standards to
keep our elderly
safe the very standards vetus is accused
of violating in the lawsuit
kay van way is the attorney who brought
the case there's
many hypocrisies associated with the
case
first of all they are a hospice company
and for anyone who's had a loved one
being taken care of
by hospice you think of them as people
who care about
people and
this company we are concerned
is more more concerned about profits
than people
because the very people that they're
charged with representing
are the people that they're endangering
so it's not just that they're
endangering their own
employees their own sales force but
they're sending
salespeople into nursing homes when they
know this is the most vulnerable
population
and so what services are they selling
they're selling hospice services so that
if people get sicker
um they benefit so many
many levels of hypocrisy okay uh
there are others who also are part of
this lawsuit
yes um both before and after we filed a
lawsuit
other sales reps both in california
and throughout the united states have
come forward with strikingly similar
stories
what's your status now with the company
christina
that's a great question i haven't heard
a word from them
um since may so you continue to be on
unpaid medical leave that's right
and finally uh if what you're alleging
is true that's a violation of the
california orders about how to deal with
covet 19
have you been contacted by any
investigators for the state of
california or for the federal government
no i haven't that surprised you
yeah it does um as a matter of fact i i
did call the local public health
authorities when when this
all first began and checked in with them
and said hey
um here's my job here's what i'm being
asked to do
i understand what your orders are and am
i in violation of your orders
by following the directives of my
company
and i was told absolutely i was however
getting anybody to investigate that
was was something that seemed next to
impossible
which is at that point when i decided to
contact an attorney
i want to thank you both for being here
very much we continue to follow the
story and
keep us posted on any reaction or
developments in the case
thank you both very much thank you
in a statement to us from venus the
company said its representatives are in
fact critical
and that the company follows all health
guidelines at the state local
and federal level coming up next winners
and losers this week
in the media see what the editors of
mediaide had to say about the
prestigious
atlantic magazine you're watching brian
ross investigates on the long crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors at mediaite and
we're joined by the editor-in-chief of
meteorite aidan mclaughlin
media of course like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media empire and aiden let's start with
your first winner a surprise i thought
the new york post that's right so the
new york post regained access to their
twitter account
this week after they were locked out by
the platform
for posting their hunter biden story now
i want to
bring this to you as a winner with an
enormous caveat this is by no means an
endorsement of
the new york post hunter biden reporting
uh which was effectively
oppo research uh that was pushed by uh
allies of president donald trump
and laundered through the new york post
given a sort of tabloid sensibility
uh the post came to some sort of you
know conclusions about that story and
about uh
joe biden's relation to hunter biden's
business dealings
that no other serious news outlet came
to those same conclusions that was
rejected by the wall street journal and
many other outlets passed on this story
but twitter
locked new york post out of its account
because it was publishing tweets that
included the story
in it and i think that was a step too
far and twitter actually got a lot of
criticism for this um you know the new
york post published a tabloid story as
the new york post
does um this story you know the hunter
biden thing is not that much different
than a lot of the more sensational
stories we had about
the trump campaign in russia a couple
years ago so
for twitter to sort of arbitrarily
mandate which stories get
uh sort of censored by the platform was
really a bad idea and twitter realized
it
and gave the new york post access back
to its account
of course but by banning it that gave it
new oxygen and it spread elsewhere
that became a more legitimate story than
the actual story they were
talking about totally the i mean the new
york post story i don't think would have
made
half the splash it did had twitter and
facebook not acted to restrict its reach
um so i think it sort of outlines the
absurdity of these social media
platforms trying to select
which news stories they approve of and
which ones they don't uh it also made
that new york post story on hunter biden
one of the biggest new york post stories
of the year
uh and they they ran you know several
covers on the basis of it
right let's move now to a loser this is
a switch this year
the loser of most prestigious magazine
atlantic magazine chosen as one of your
losers why is that right i think it was
it was an interesting selection this
week that we had a tabloid like the new
york post as a winner and
a venerable magazine like the atlantic
is the loser but the atlantic
was forced to print a massive 800 word
correction
to a story that came out this week uh or
last week and it was also in the
magazine
and they eventually retracted the story
altogether this week
it was a long-form dive the piece into
parents in a tony connecticut suburb
were pushing their children into niche
sports to give them a leg up when
applying to colleges that's what the
story was about
but the piece was written by ruth
charlotte who back in the 1990s was
a pretty popular magazine writer she
wrote her gq
she was a writer at the new republic
before she flamed out in this pretty
shocking plagiarism scandal uh now after
she submitted this piece to the atlantic
they apparently
said you know it's been decades she's
been published elsewhere we're
comfortable publishing this piece by her
they ran their fact checking process on
it which was very thorough
but a washington post media critic eric
wempel actually looked into the story
and found a series of inaccuracies on it
which were quite glaring
and the atlantic then did their second
fact check and they deemed that the
writer had deceived them
they published this massive and scathing
800 word correction to the piece
eventually retracted it it's a pretty it
you know it's a bruise for a magazine
that
has actually a very good reputation for
printing factual stories
um but i i have to say it sounds like
they should have known better
and they seem to have acknowledged bad
judgment
for sure yeah they said that that ruth
charlotte deceived them but that they
should have known that uh you know to
backtrack this more clearly and you know
one of the mistakes was a pretty glaring
one
uh one of ruth charlotte's top sources
said that she had a daughter and told
some of these elaborate stories about
her daughter's sporting activities and
then revealed that she
actually didn't have a daughter and the
atlantic said that even the the writer
may have actually pushed
her source to deceive her
amazing amazing ladies mclaughlin thank
you so much for joining us we'll be
looking forward to seeing you next week
to talk about election coverage
that's it for tonight thank you so much
for joining us and thanks for the great
team at law and crime
for getting us on and off the air
[Music]
so
you